moon knight spider-man 2099 solid snake
oscar isaac's career is already on fire
but could he also take on one of
marvel's most badass heroes one digital
artist is making our wolverine casting
dreams come true in case you weren't
aware it's a very good time to be oscar
isaac the acting megastar has been on a
roll recently with parts in denis
villeneuve's acclaimed 2021 epic dune
and the recently finished moon knight
series on disney plus and isaac's future
seems just as bright in 2023 the actor
will be reprising his role as spider-man
2099 aka miguel o'hara in spider-man
across the spider-verse and he's also
set to portray the iconic video game
character solid snake in a proposed
movie adaptation of metal gear solid of
course when you're as hot as isaac
currently is there's no such thing as
enough the thing about a beloved actor
appearing in a number of well-received
projects is that the fandom is always
hungry for more knowing this it's no
surprise that fans have yet another
legendary character in mind whose shoes
isaac could fill
yeah yes exactly new art posted online
by the digital artist r infinity shows
what it might look like if isaac assumed
the mantle of marvel's wolverine who was
first famously played on the big screen
by hugh jackman isaac has already
stepped into marvel's cinematic world of
mutants as the villain apocalypse in
2016's x-men apocalypse and now with his
recent marvel cinematic universe
experience as moon knight there's never
been a better time to give the man a
crack at a more mainstream superhero
role there are those who think isaac
would be awesome as wolverine and now
they have the mind-blowing artwork to
back up the idea first posted on
deviantart and instagram our affinity's
oscar isaac fan casting of wolverine is
as picture perfect as it is comics
accurate the look somewhat resembles the
relatively muted design hugh jackman's
logan sports in the first x-men movie
back in 2000 thanks to the shabby
civilian clothes long sideburns and a
hairdo that seems to screw toward
unkempt mane instead of elaborately
styled points exposed claws and splashes
of red on the face indicate that this
version of wolverine has recently been
in conflict and the expression on his
face makes clear that he's ready for
more it's a design that's already
attracted plenty of attention from fans
and drawn comparison between isaacs and
wolverine's comic book look while fit
isaac is somewhat shorter and stockier
compared to hugh jackman which makes him
much closer in stature to how logan is
portrayed in the comics he appears
smaller yet more battle hardened than
jackman's finally muscled weapon x
though still very clearly played by a
handsome hollywood star this version of
wolverine comes across as somewhat less
glamorous as if he spent more time
fighting than working on his six-pack
moon knight which saw him step into the
title role as a hero whose power comes
from an egyptian god proves that isaac
has versatility and intensity to spare
with the right haircut in an adequately
impressive sideburn game there's every
reason to believe that the actor would
rock the role of marvel's favorite
claude newton it's also pretty safe to
say that fans would likely love to see
isaac as wolverine what's even better
though is the fact that isaac has made
multiple comments about how much he
likes wolverine in march 2022 the actor
told fandom that wolverine and
apocalypse were his favorite x-men
characters when he was young an
intriguing comment since he's already
managed to cross playing one of them
from his bucket list he also noted that
he loved wolverine in part because in
the comics he's a short superhero
something isaac himself could relate to
speaking to esquire around the same time
isaac again commented on feeling a
connection with wolverine noting
wolverine's a little guy in the comics
at least he was you know furry and angry
and i could relate to that between the
revelation that isaac likes wolverine
and the fact that he'd clearly fit the
role very well it's easy to get excited
about the prospect of him joining the
x-men as their grumpiest member of
course as astute fans might notice there
are some significant hurdles between
reality and this fun piece of fan
casting isaac's stint as apocalypse was
prosthetic heavy and very very blue so
it wouldn't necessarily disqualify him
from another x-men role however thanks
to professor charles xavier's appearance
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness marvel's mutants are inching
ever closer to the marvel cinematic
universe where isaac already embodies
the many personalities of moon knight
still if all else fails maybe the mcu
will one day adapt the comic book
storyline where wolverine becomes one of
moon knight's alternate personalities it
would be a nice way to kill two birds
with one stone check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about marvel stars are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]